usually it's the contestants who break  down on the bachelor parts of the test  I don't know just I'm certain Nate  scares me not did the bachelors a mom  but Emily the last standing twin did  make Ben Higgins momma burst into tears  on Monday night's episode because she  wasn't just so awkward in Emily's  defense that she didn't know she was  going to meet Ben's parents on that date  talking to people can kind of be a hard  thing for me I get really like anxious  and I just want to make sure that like I  don't make an idiot of myself but still  she made it weird I've dreamed of being  an NFL cheerleader for as long as I can  remember so um Denver Broncos would be  very a great team to cheer for so I mean  she's definitely a really fun individual  needless to say Emily got sent home  before the rose ceremony I just don't  think I can see you being my wife  hey I'm just emotional